ابحث الشرطه العراقيه عن طفل ظهر في مقطع
فيديو ليله الاحتفال براس السنه داخل ملهى
ليلي الطفل كان يمطر الاموال على راقصه
وسط اجواء صاخبه ما اثار ردود فعل غاضبه
المدونين على مواقع التواصل ابدا استغرابه
ومن السماح لطفل بدخول ملهى ليلي رغم ان
ذلك يتنافى مع القوانين والقيود التي
تفرضها السلطات العراقيه لذلك دعم مدير
الشرطه المجتمعيه العميد غالب العطيه عبر
صفحته في فيسبوك الى تزويد معلومات عن
الطفل حيث جاري البحث عنه
من راس راسي
[موسيقى]
سالنا الشارع العراقي من المسؤول عن تواجد
هذا الطفل في الملهى
تصير الاسره المفروض انه الاسره التابع
الاطفال تابع طلعتهم حركتهم
حسوني
الاب والام والله العظيم اني ما اعرف اصلا
ماكو ناس ماكو ما تعرفوا اولادها وين راحت
للمدرسه راحوا للملهى راحوا الكوفي هنا
الدوله مسؤوله بالشطر الثاني اما الشطر
الاول فهو مسؤوله عنه العائله من بعد 2003
واليومك التعليم مو ذاك التعليم النظام مو
ذاك النظام هذا كلي ياثر يا رجل اولى
الحكومه كونه يتم تمنح تراخيص لفتح هذه
الاماكن احنا نعرف من هذه الاماكن تابعه
لها حمايه حتى تفتح
[موسيقى]
من بغداد تنضم الينا رئيسه منظمه الحقوق
الانسان حقوق المراه والطفل الانسان سلمان
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك طفل متواجد في ملهى
ليلي يمطر راقصه بالاموال تفاصيل اوف فان
كانت لديكم منظمه مسؤوله عن حقوق الطفل
صباح الخير عليك عزيزتي وعلى جميع كادر
العربيات طبعا هو ماكو غرابه بالنسبه
لنادين وموثقين لانتهاكات حقوق الانسان
وحقوق الطفوله على وجه الخصوص او تواجد
طفل في ملهى ليلي لكن هي الكاميرات وثقت
هذا الشيف طلع للاعلام وصارتجه هذا انتهاك
واضح وحقيقي
لحقوق الطفوله بالعراق مع شديد الاسف مثل
هذا الطفل المفروض ينشر لها فيديو بتميز
بدراسه وهو يدرس اللغه الانجليزيه او
المساله رياضيه صعبه مثل ما بتعرف عليها
بقيه البلدان لكن للاسف اليوم الطفوله
وحقوق الطفوله على الرغم من ان العراق
بقوانين حقيقيه مختصه بالطفوله والعراق
صادق على همم اتفاقيه حق الطفل همم وكذلك
على على البروتو كولين ال- ال- الملحقين
الخاص يعني الخاصه بالاطفال اللي هي
الاتجار بالاطفال طبعا هو هذا يعني يمثل
جزء او يمثل حاله من حاله الاشجار
بالطفوله وايضا البروتوكول الخاص بمنع
استخدام الاطفال الفترات الحرب نعم طيب
انسان يعني المتابع للفيديو لتعبير وجه
طفل يعني يبدو عليه السعاده وكانه مش
مغصوب انه يجيء على هذا المكان بالتالي
يعني مسؤوليه اتمنى اليوم كيف دخل الى هذا
الملح
طبعا هو اكيد باين عليه السعاده لان هو
متربي في بيئه وموجود ضمن بيئه هذه البيئه
اييه يعني متعايشه مع فكره تواجدها
بالنوادي الليليه هو طفل يعني هو غير واعي
غير بالغ هو ما يفتهم هذا المكان خطر هذا
المكان غلط ويحس بالوجود هذا المكان انجاز
حس روحه انه هو كبير اكو تشجيع اكو تصفيه
اكو حاله من السعاده للمحيطين للاجابه هذا
المكان المسؤوليه الحقيقيه بالدرجه الاولى
هي غياب الرقابه الحكوميه غياب التعليم
الزامي احنا للاسف عندنا التعليم الزامي
فقط ممكن الابتدائيه بالقانون لكن هو منفذ
بطريقه حقيقيه اساليب التفعيل القوانين
بالعراق للاسف هي اساليب قديمه وغير
موجوده يعني المفروض يكون التعليم الزاميم
من يعني من همم من الابتدائي
واقوى رقابه حكوميه تحاسب الاهل
الطفل
وصور بهذه الطريقه من يحاسب قانونيا خصوصا
انه بحسب القوانين العراقيه ممنوع دخول
الاطفال الى الملاهي الليليه هل يحاسب
الاهل هل يحاسب الملهى يعني من المحاسب
اكيد هو يحاسب المفروض يتعرض الى المساء
الى القانونيه ويغلق
واصحاب يعني يتم محاسبتهم هذا الشيء بديهي
المفروض
الاخرى انه نبحث هذا الطفل لانه هذا الطفل
يتيم الابوين هذا الطفل مشرد هذا الطفل
كيف كان دخوله الى المنهج الصحاب من تم
دخول الى الملعب طبعا كثير من الاطفال
نساء يعني بنات بعمر المراهقه ويعني بعمر
ال 10 سنوات
يعني من فتره قصيره بهذا الموضوع حل
الاشكال انه هذا انه اليوم اليوم المدونين
والناشطين والمدافعين عن حقوق الانسان
تناول الفيديو انشره لتشكيل الضغط واصبح
قضيه رائعه
في الشارع راينا طفل
نعمل حلته واناقته يرتت البدله وكانه جاهز
مستعد لحفله راس السنه يمطر راقصه باموال
يعني يبدو علي بانه وضعه مرتاح ماديا فهنا
الخطوره نحن اليوم لا نتحدث عن اشخاص غير
متعلمين فقراء معدمين في الشارع
نقدر نقول هي عمليه مترابطه يعني انا ما
اقدر اليوم احدد اقول انه لا فقط
المشاهدين ممكن يدخلوا ما هو شلون صار
يعني يعني على اي اساس انت مو فقط اليوم
تكون انه اذا انت فقير ممكن يعني المتعجله
بك احنا ما نعرف حقيقه الحاله الحكومه
العراقيه والشرطه المجتمعيه ده تبحث حسب
لحد الان عنه وين موجود هذا النادي الليلي
وكيف تم اصحابه الطفل
المفروض بعد يعني يعرفون اي ما لها هذا او
اي نادي هذا اللي تم ب همم انه الترويج
لفكره وجود الاطفال راح يتم يعني نشر
الحاله بالتفاصيل الحقيقيه لكن بالواقع
بغض النظر اذا كانت الطفل الفقير او كان
الطفل غني وجود الاطفال وهمم استعمال
واستخدام الاطفال للترويج ليه النوادي
الليليه وكانها يعني انما هذا الشيء صحيح
ومباح هذا ينتهك الطفوله وينتهيك الحاله
الانسانيه والنشاه لان الطفل هاي سنوات
الاولى من حياتها هي اللي تشكل شخصيته هنا
راح تشبع افكار راح يعني يعني الغرائز
تكون اسرع تنمو بشكل اسرع يحب يكبر بشكل
سريع حتى يكون هو رجل لان الموجودين بهذا
المكان يروج الى على انهم رجال والنساء
مباحثات والموضوع مالدي هنا احنا هنخلق
همم للاسف مجرم مجتمعي همم
متربي بداخل نادي طفل بكى امر بهيجه
المفروض يكون نايم بالبيت مستعد انه ثاني
يوم عنده دراسه وعنده دراسه ويكون مثابر
ويكون مجتهد وهو وهو لوقت متاخر وهو
بينادي ليلي اي مثال هذا ممكن يحتدى به
الاطفال اليوم ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
والهواتف النقاله بيد الاطفال تخيلي يعني
انه يشوفون هذا طفل بالنادي فهذا راح تخلي
فضول يزداد الفضول همم بداخل الاطفال
الباقين والطفل يحب يقلد بطبيعه الحال
الطفل ما يفرق بين الصح والخطا لانه هو
بعد دماغها يعني ما ناضج نضوج التام ما
عنده وعي كامل فاحنا هنا راح نكون سبب اذا
تركنا هذه الحاله اليوم انتشر فيديو باكر
ينتشر اخر واخر واخر الموضوع راح يتفاقم
احنا بيجي حاله احنا نستهدف الاطفال حتى
نوعيهم حتى نقلق اجيال جديده قائده
اجتماعيه حقيقيه تفهم همم الحقوق وتفهم
كيف يعني تحافظ على حقوقها والطالب
بحقوقها وتكون هي يعني نماذج واعيه
وحقيقيه بالمجتمع وفذ يحتذى بها كيف انه
اليوم اشوف الفئه اللي استهدفها للاسف
موجوده بال- النادي الليلي وموضوع
الراقصه وموضوع وجود الطفل وكانه متعه
وكانها طالعين يعني للزوراء يعني احنا ما
رايحين مكان هذا المكان ما المفروض يتواجد
من المحرمات وجود الاطفال مع شديد الاسف
انا طالب من يعني من منبركم انه هو قناتكم
العزيزه اطالب الحكومه العراقيه على انه
تنزل اشد العقوبات بكل نادي ليلي بكل مكان
همم يعني يكون
المسؤوله
عن وجود الطفل وحتى عن مكان المنهل شكرا
جزيلا من بغداد رئيسه منظمه حقوق المراه
والطفل شكرا لك